Welcome back to The David Pakman Show. This is
funny to see one of Trump's kids, Eric Trump,
went on the Fox News program
hosted by Sean Hannity last night.
And I have clips of both Eric Trump and his wife,
Laura Trump. Actually, the power couple of sorts
just really struggling to cope with the defeat,
really defeat after defeat that the Republican
Party is suffering. Trump losing these interviews
happening as Republican incumbents in Georgia,
in the Senate were also losing. And as the
interview went on, you see that they are now
starting to become vindictive in a sense. And
in this first clip, Eric Trump says, seemingly
acknowledging that they've lost everything,
that the Magga movement is going nowhere.
But more importantly, Eric Trump threatens
any Republican who today, January 6th,
when the House and Senate convene to count the
electoral votes, it may already be happening. By
the time you listen today, Eric Trump Trump warns
we are going to have a list. Any Republican that
doesn't help today to steal the election, you were
getting primaried. Of course, this assumes that
Trump will have any kind of power after he
leaves office. We still don't know that.
But here is Eric Trump tomorrow to tell you a lot
about the country, because I can tell you, Sean,
any senator or any congressman, that does not
mean on this side that does not fight tomorrow,
I'm telling you, will not. Their political career
is over because the Maggert movement is going it's
going nowhere. My fathers created the greatest
political movement in American history. And
I'm telling you, they will get primaried
the next time around and they will lose
if they don't stand up and show some
backbone and show some conviction.
So there it is. Eric Trump threatening the
political careers of any Republican who
doesn't get in line, shut their mouth,
or I guess open their mouth to support
the Trump coup that is destined to fail. Imagine
saying, by the way, this is really delusional.
After losing the house in twenty
eighteen, so Trump gets elected in 2016,
Republicans lose the House in twenty
eighteen. Don't get it back in 2020,
they lose the Senate in 2020. And Trump becomes
a one term president, which is of course not
unheard of, but it's relatively rare. I mean,
it's tough to remove an incumbent president.
And Eric Trump has the audacity to say Trump ism
is the greatest political movement in history.
This is the type of delusion where we narcissists
don't realize when they have no leverage.
That's a really important characteristic
of very serious narcissism. And, of course,
Eric Trump was I mean, I guess raised by it's not
really clear who raised these Trump kids Trump.
It's not clear Trump likes his kids that much, but
at least in some vague sense, they were raised by
Donald Trump, at least the idea of Donald Trump
as their father and Trump much like his kids,
they don't know when they don't have leverage.
Very often they do have leverage. They are
powerful people and they've been
powerful really most of their lives.
And there's no denying that. But even
when they no longer have the leverage,
they still think they do. And Eric Trump saying
this is the greatest political movement. You've
lost everything. Why are you assuming that you're
going to continue having leverage or influence
over the party? They might, but they might not.
And then Eric Trump still claiming that there's
just no way Joe Biden got all those votes.
I mean, no one believes that this guy got 80
million votes. It doesn't feel
right. It doesn't look right.
Again, with the feelings. I thought facts
didn't care about your feelings. I've heard
that from the right for a decade at this point.
But he just doesn't feel like Donald Trump
really lost. So what do we do with that? I
guess as far as they're concerned, you steal
the election and then the softball interviews with
Trump family members continued last night on Fox.
Erick, Trump's wife, Laura Trump also appearing
and hilariously, she is still being identified
as Trump campaign senior adviser, which, of
course, should make us ask, what campaign are
you talking about? That campaign ended two
months ago, senior adviser to the campaign.
And she says, I truly believe Trump will probably
consider running in twenty four. What a strong
statement. Right. But talking about 2024 does
implicitly concede that Donald Trump lost this
time. So that's something. But she's still
kind of careful not to say it. Take a listen.
Look, if he does not remain president for the next
four years, I truly believe that he will probably
consider running again in twenty, twenty four. I
believe he would win in twenty twenty four by a
larger margin of victory than he even did. I guess
then the more votes than he had in this election.
But so that that's just really
amazing. I mean first of all,
what conviction right now. I really do believe.
That if he doesn't get another four
years now, he will probably consider
running in twenty, twenty four.
To me, that means he's not running
running in 2024. That's what I'm hearing from
the language that Larry Trump is using. But
the coping mechanisms are very different for
different folks in the Republican Party. There
are those who are just abandoning altogether
and pretending none of this horrible thing ever
happened. There are those who are still insisting
any second now Trump's going to be sworn in. In
fact, I posted to my Twitter, you can see it this
morning. I posted a message I got today. I posted
this message I got today and people thought
it was months old today. Someone said to me,
David, don't you realize Trump's getting
a second term right now? Biden's not.
So some people continuing to be in denial.
And I know that there's just one cautionary
mention here. I know there are people in
my audience waiting for the big payoff
where on January 22nd, all of these people admit
they were wrong. You're not going to get that.
You're not going to get that satisfaction because
on January 20th, 21st, 22nd, they will come up
with some new thing and say it was stolen in this
way and that way. And none of it is legitimate.
So if you're waiting for that satisfaction,
you're going to be waiting a very long time.